sur l'agriculture est ce qu'il y en a
qui veut répondre
nicolas je pense que la question de
notre avis de david et sa franchise
mérite une réponse aussi franche d'abord
david vous avez souligné le comporte des
comportements qui vous plaisent pas ce
qui est tout à fait votre droit moi je
veux souligner que ce matin jean pierre
raffarin nous honore de sa présence
alors qu'il était déjà là hier michèle
alliot marie tient à être présent
je voudrais l'en remercier et je ne suis
pas sûr que tout le monde aurait eu
cette élégance je l'en remercie le
président du sénat excusez moi qui dans
l'ordre protocolaire de la république
nous honore de sa présence ou si il
n'était pas obligé de le faire je
pourrais multiplier les exemples
non mais non parce que je vais continuer
et je vais me flinguer avec tout ce que
je répare saluer sais pas c'était pas la
volonté de david
bon je vais aller plus loin la politique
david genest dans le sang j'y peux rien
il y en a qui sont tombé dans la potion
magique pour moi la politique c'est ça
ne croyez pas que j'ai pas vu la
différence des résultats d'une région à
l'autre
permettez moi là une grille de lecture
par tous
où nos candidats et nos têtes de liste
ont fait une campagne politique et non
pas une comptable de notables partout
ils ont sorti le drapeau où ils ont
affirmé leur conviction
ils ont rassemblé l'électorat de la
droite et du centre partout on a voulu
faire une campagne exclusivement locale
on s'est trompés parce que les
régionales avec ses grandes régions
c'était des élections profondément
politique et c'était pas des élections
régionales régionalistes voilà ce que je
pense et quelles que soient les
sensibilités des uns raison je suis sûr
que c'est ça et j'en tirais d'ailleurs
pas beaucoup de conclusions
si ce n'est à tous ceux qui m'expliquait
que laurent wauquiez s'était pas le bon
candidat qu'il fallait pour rhône alpes
auvergne
je leur dédie le résultat formidable
qu'a fait laurent en rhône-alpes et en
auvergne
heureusement qu'on avait choisi un
mauvais candidat
qu'est ce que ça serait si on avait
choisi un bon je veux dire que la
campagne café valérie pécresse en
ile-de-france qui était une campagne
profondément politique qu'elle a menée
avec un courage et un engagement
exceptionnel c'est ça si valérie l'avait
fait la campagne qu'en discutant avec
les élus les maires les conseillers
départementaux pardon elles seraient
passés à côté de la logique de ces
élections régionales qui est des
élections au suffrage universel
je pourrais multiplier les exemples
notamment avec bruno retailleau les
primaires je vous parlais très
franchement les primaires ne sont plus
un sujet de débat entre nous parce que
nous avons décidé qu'il y aurait des
primaires il y aura des primaires je
prends mes responsabilités et vous
verrez tout à l'heure vous ne serez pas
déçus mais les primaires
je me suis engagé à ce qu'elles aient
lieu il y avait ceux qui étaient pour il
y avait ceux qui étaient contre
il y avait ceux qui étaient hésitants
mais la formation politique qui est la
nôtre qui a pris une décision
les primaires auront lieu entre
septembre et novembre
elles sont financées il ya une
organisation
thierry solère il ya une autorité
indépendante
je vous propose
de mettre toute votre énergie à ce que
ces primaires se passent le mieux
possible
plutôt qu à débattre à l'infini de
savoir si elles auront lieu aux généraux
banlieue elles auront lieu il ya une
ligne politique est une formation
politique ne revient pas sur sa ligne
tous les quatre matins pardon pardon
d'être directif mais franchement
sinon je sais bien qu'ils aient pas
d'homme providentiel mais moi je crois à
l'organisation à l'autorité un minimum
de discipline
et quand on a pris une décision on la
met en oeuvre sinon c'est pas la peine
de m'expliquer qu'il faut faire un
projet en me demandant est-ce que vous
mettrez en oeuvre ce que vous avez
promis si on commence par dire les
primaires on en parle on les a décidés
et on n'y sera pas bon troisièmement
vous êtes des responsables politiques le
plus simple adhérent est un responsable
politique
faites votre jugement sur le
comportement des uns des autres en toute
liberté
ne me demandez pas de commenter votre
jugement parce que tout ce que je ferais
consistera à marquer un but contre notre
propre famille politique et contre la
france je m'y refuse
vous êtes libre de penser que certains
on sait bien qu'ils viennent
ou c'est pas bien qu'ils viennent pas
mais si votre jugement et vous n'avez
pas besoin de demander notre avis notre
accord ou notre approbation les
républicains c'est un parti libre vous
pensez ce que vous voulez mais vous
comprenez qu'il ya un domaine où ma
liberté de parole n'est pas de la
liberté parce que ça doit être de la
responsabilité c'est celui qui consiste
à juger ce que font ou ce que ne font
pas les autres moi je sais parfaitement
que vous connaissez tous les codes que
vous décrypter toutes les attitudes
mais à l'arrivée c'est vous qui
déciderez voilà